so he's using private aircraft these
days well customers break down into
about four groups so you've got your
charter companies you want to take the
gang down to Miami for a weekend you got
a spare 10 grand lying around you got
yourself a plane my friend next up or
your prepaid which are kind of like
prepaid phone plans but instead of
getting 1,500 minutes of talk time for
30 dollars you're getting 25 hours of
playing time for 100,000
then you're a fractional ownership it's
like a timeshare and you can use it
whenever you want but you have equity so
if things go south you sell your share
the most baller option of course is to
own your own place but buying a plane is
only part of the deal private aircraft
are less like cars and more like horses
they need to be stable
that's where companies like Jet Aviation
commence Teterboro is only 18 miles from
Newark Airport but its worlds apart as
an experience what's going to happen
here is I'm going to meet my pilot North
mayor just waiting here for me inside
the terminal building is nice but
nothing special but you're not going to
be spending a lot of time in it your
aircraft is likely waiting right outside
and there's no TSA line
if you wanted to charter a plane from
jet aviation to take you from say
Teterboro to London it would run you
between 75 and 95 thousand dollars for
that you would get a pilot a copilot and
flight attendant thank you so you may be
wondering how all of this feels it feels
amazing in fact I have to fly
commercially next week and going from
this two-seat thirty-four app is going
to be a huge letdown